después de la salida de las farc muchos
territorios están en una guerra y en esa
guerra no hay ganadores todavía y como
ningún actor es capaz de ganarle al otro
la han emprendido contra la población
civil lo segundo es que efectivamente
hay una disputa por economías ilegales y
están en una explosión impresionante el
precio del oro el precio de la pasta
base de coca van hacia arriba y la
economía de la plaza de personas y lo
tercero es que en muchos territorios
estar atentando contra organizaciones
civiles particulares como lo que pasó
hace algunas horas en argelia cauca que
destruye una organización social
completa mataron a su líder caballo en
militante y ahí tenemos lo dramático
esto el próximo año que es un año
preelectoral pareciera ser que iba a ser
muy violento